thank you thank you yes I am this pale
alright not naturally I just wanted
Conan to feel tan it is good to be here
I I feel a little nauseous though I had
a hot pocket for dinner anybody else
have a hot pocket never really see that
on a menu when you go out to dinner
let's see I will have the Caesar salad
and the hot pocket today's specials we
have a filet mignon which is flambe and
we have a hot pocket which is cooked in
a dirty microwave and that comes with a
side of Metamucil is your hot pocket
cold in the middle it's frozen oh I'll
have the hot pocket I buy hot pockets
you are going grocery stores I'm like yo
get these I've never eaten a hot pocket
and then afterwards Ben I'm gonna die I
paid for that I was looking at a box my
pocket save a warning printed on the
side said warning you just bought hot
pockets
hope you're drunk or heading home to a
trailer you hillbilly enjoy the next
NASCAR event
highpockets haven't been around that
long how'd they come up with them is
there like some guy in a marketing
meeting 10 years ago how about a
pop-tart filled with meat Johnson that's
disgusting get to work on it now they've
got the vegetarian hot pocket for those
of us that don't want to eat meat but
still want diarrhea the stuff should
just come with a roll of toilet paper
you think they worked hard on that song
what do you got so far bill hot pocket
what are we gonna run in Mexico caliente
pocket sounds like a sexual disorder
doesn't it look Bobby sometimes when
fellas don't go on dates they develop
what we call a hot pocket doesn't mean
you're bad it just means you need a
girlfriend you know I love see eating a
hot pocket would be the Pope huh does
anyone look more tired than the Pope
ever see the Pope on TV they go
poor guy God's working them to death
Oh get up you got 10 more countries to
go to you know you're tired when you
can't support your head
is that had filled with lead what a bit
weird if you went to high school with
the Pope somebody somebody sit at home
watching TV and Poland they see the Pope
on TV either that guy was a jerk I think
would be great if you had a kid that
ended up being Pope that would be the
ultimate bragging rights Oh your son's a
doctor yeah ours is Pope it's okay for
himself oh they have a house he has his
own city in Europe you think when the
Pope was little kitty fantasize about
eventually being Pope you know we might
about being a professional athlete was
he like eight years old in this backyard
going
[Music]
I was raised Catholic my dad you saw has
volunteered me for the reading in church
I'd be like six years old to be like you
over doing the reading never up mic
glasses so I wouldn't be able to read
I'd be like oh letter from Peter to the
apostille
post somebody kill me I'd rather go and
read up here you know it's church you're
reading from the Bible it's now you
could make something up you can get the
first line and then ad-lib a letter from
Peter to the Apostles
dear apostles Jesus this is the word of
the Lord thank you very much
Jimmy advocator everybody was gonna
break